hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play lost the lights and what may
be the final episode but we're gonna
find out okay Wow
open there anybody this looks normal
have a closed-up place here little can i
crocheter their hand
oh I can I used to go that way I see in
torch over there any strangers here
though I'll check it out this may be the
last episode so it might be real short
so I guess I see with everything shaking
so much it don't matter what the hell I
guess this really is a war zone I doubt
that you know machine guns and
explosions and bombs dropping could have
tossed that all right see what's going
on okay
I know this is supposed to seem like
tall grass but it just makes me feel
really short but once again this guy is
doing a tremendous job with did David
warm me for this this guy's doing a
tremendous job with environments I mean
no one's made outdoor environments in
any they look like this explosion no
one's made that means you look like
anything in this body this guy I know
I've bitched about some small aspects
but those are just minor stuff and
mostly my fault anyway
I mean what should I expect a game
shouldn't like to hold your hands throw
away all this shooting in barb Barton
did the Power Core release his force the
force did I create the Tex World War
yeah yeah Daniel you're a dick you're
kind of a douchebag in that regard I
don't remember seeing that graphic whoa
ah damn it I closed my eyes and said
nothing did not hang and the time
stopped moving and I suddenly realized I
realized it never was a good idea to
overload an unknown power without
knowing what the consequences were true
dat I created chaos and death to those
poor people I deserve to die for this
maybe he does do you hear me grunts I'm
ready kill me my body's ready really
really don't tell me that's the end what
I mean ha ha oh man was there were there
different endings I don't think so
because on every custom story I've done
there hasn't been I wouldn't be
surprised you know but anyway Wow
I gotta say that was really really an
incredibly well done all music hmm
probably too loud for my voice anyway
but I really really enjoyed that come on
that was fantastic phenomenal being
things he did with the limited resources
he had was incredible he made amnesia
look like a totally different game
through half of the entire story and
integrating penumbra graphics in it too
just added that level of complexity that
it needed I mean it was kind of weird
with um 6 months to create lost lights I
would believe it I would believe it I
mean it's just it's crazy with you know
doing it in six months anyway that's for
as long as it was this has been like a
five six hour let's play that's crazy
for a custom I mean what this is the
nineteenth part 18 I'm not sure no
seriously thanks for making the game and
the credit to English is fine the end
well he kind of got murdered to death by
the grunts so I'm not sure anyway
that was an incredible incredible let's
play I have nothing but praise for that
guy you saw his name I couldn't read it
myself
but God and play yourself and if he has
a donate button
some money o99 maybe there was different
endings maybe I'll look into it I'll do
some research and maybe there'll be
enough if there is more endings I'll do
another episode and try to try to get
into the other one
but for now thank you guys so much for
watching I know there's a short one but
I mean it's the end I wanted to fit it
all in one episode I like to do my my
end of the game monologues I like
talking about I like the sound of my own
voice in case you didn't know but anyway
thanks again everybody for watching I
really do appreciate and I hope you like
this as much cited and as always I will
see you in the next part video in the
next video bye bye